Speaker 1: I want to start today with something
that's kind of really good news.
Some in the audience have grown increasingly
frustrated with me that I have not really
put out my sense of a way to radically deprogram
right wing extremists and reactionaries from
fact free Trumpism or ignorant political ideas.
Call it what you will, but the question that
we've been kind of grappling with is, OK,
great.
Tens of millions of people think Trump actually
won.
They would vote for him again.
They believe untrue things about vaccines
and climate change and the pandemic and all
these different things.
We've identified a problem.
How do we fix it?
And at the individual level, we know, well,
you know, if you spend three hours, six hours
with individuals, you can change some minds.
But that's a really difficult thing to do
at a at a sort of large scale.
At the same time, when we think about something
from above that radically and quickly changes
views, we're often talking about significant
authoritarianism, which as a progressive,
I am against authoritarianism.
So we don't really have an answer.
But we now have a new study that is really
inspiring and reassuring that it is possible,
although what we can actually do as a result
remains a question mark.
So I'm talking about a incredible new study
called The Manifold Effects of Partizan Media
on viewers beliefs and attitudes, a field
experiment with Fox News viewers.
And there's a good write up of what this did,
and essentially what they did is they took
Fox News viewers and they paid them.
They paid them to watch CNN for 30 days.
And what they found was that after watching
CNN for 30 days, the Fox News viewers became
more skeptical about fake actual fake news,
less likely to buy into fake news.
And they also found changes in attitudes and
policy preferences on COVID 19, on evaluations
of then-President Trump and of Republican
candidates.
And they wrote, and this is so not incredible.
But but it's a good thing.
Despite regular Fox News viewers being largely
strong partizans, we found manifold effects
of changing the slant of their media diets
on their factual beliefs, attitudes, perceptions
of issues, importance and overall political
views.
They write it found that Fox News gave viewers
information about why the disease is not a
serious threat, while CNN provided more information
about the disease itself.
This changed people's views and it goes on,
and it says a lot more about what was done
here.
And this is important for so many different
reasons now, obviously.
If you think CNN is bad and not trustworthy
on the facts, then you would see this as bad.
You would say, Wow, they they believe the
right things when they watch Fox News.
And after 30 days of watching CNN, all of
a sudden they believe all these liberal lies
now on these particular issues.
We know during the pandemic, when Trump was
president, Fox News was giving a very skewed
perspective of the pandemic and about other
issues.
So you can argue as to whether it's a good
thing or not that they end up believing what
they see on CNN rather than what they see
on Fox.
But that's not the issue I want to focus in
on.
The incredible good news is if we put the
right information in front of people, we can
debate what the right information is.
But if we put the right information, if we
put accurate information in front of people,
their beliefs are not as resistant to revision
as we might have thought.
And the other kind of scary aspect of this
is it reminds us of the significant impact
of one's media diet.
It's incredible.
Or maybe not.
Maybe we say it's disturbing what happens
to people's beliefs when their media diet
is restricted to what we might call extremist
media or disinformation media?
And to some extent, I will gladly concede
that CNN profits off of and depends on fear
mongering salacious stories.
The kind of if it bleeds, it leads the most
extremist and hyperbolic interpretation of
things with a different perspective than Fox
News, but CNN is nowhere near as dishonest.
We have to understand the kind of corporate
fear leads framing when I was on my flight
to Las Vegas.
In fact, there was a guy sitting across the
aisle from me and I was a long flight from
the East Coast.
Five and a half six hours, I watched him consume
hours of Fox News, but then later in the flight,
I looked over and MSNBC was on, and it was
interesting because I was reading this study
on the flight as I was watching the sky.
And we might wrongly say, Well, the MSNBC's
is going to have no impact on the guy.
And what the study shows is that it does.
Now again, MSNBC is a not as dishonest.
Editorially liberal corporate media outlets,
so for me, MSNBC is not exactly the solution
to Fox News and what this gets me back to,
as many people are kind of addicted to outrage,
fear, anger and validation of their existing
views as well, because the anger gives people
sometimes what is like a temporary relief
from what are maybe more difficult feelings
to deal with, you know, despair in their lives
or a feeling of helplessness, helplessness
or whatever the case may be.
Conspiracy content, as we've talked about
before, is sometimes soothing to people because
they would rather believe everything is planned
and orchestrated rather than there are random
bad events that we really can't pre